in 1981
an arcade in portland was the scene of
countless gamers coming down with
migraines
having heart attacks seizures and
strokes local teens were suffering from
amnesia
and having hallucinations all due to a
mysterious game
that seemed to arrive out of thin air
the game was called polybius
and even though playing the game was
dangerous it was highly addictive
and caused some teens to become hyper
aggressive
fights started breaking out of the
arcade one player was stabbed to death
all traced back to people who played
polybius now why would the government
allow the public to play such a
dangerous game
well because the government created it
let's find out why
[Music]
if you've never heard the urban legend
about polybius here's how it goes
in 1981 a portland arcade received a
video game called polybius
that had gameplay unlike anything anyone
had ever seen before
the player would stare at random
geometric patterns and strange shapes
causing them to fall into a sort of
hypnotic state the game was known for
its psychedelic images
unsettling soundtrack and subliminal
messages
and if you play polybius it could cause
all kinds of physiological effects
amnesia anxiety night terrors aggression
insomnia
it could also cause physical effects
like migraine headaches
nausea vertigo even heart attacks and
strokes
polybius was created by a company named
sinus lotion
which in german roughly translates to
sense deleting
after playing two portland teenagers
disappeared without a trace
some say they were abducted others say
they were recruited
now this game was so addictive that
players would line up around the block
and get into physical
fights in order to play it people
reported that the polybius machines
were watching players and collecting
data about them
that data was periodically retrieved by
men in black suits
who serviced the machines and the story
goes that these men in black
could change the game's attributes in
order to elicit
different responses from the players
mind control
yep grab my hat please
thank you the game was only released in
two arcades and only for a short time
then it disappeared as quickly and as
quietly as it arrived never to be seen
again
now this is an urban legend and it's a
good one but how much of it is true
well actually more than most people
but it think just any game you have been
recruited
to defend the frontier against
to get to the truth of the story of
polybius you have to dig pretty deep
and if you google polyvias you'll get a
bunch of blurry images of an arcade
cabinet there's no way to tell if these
are photoshopped or an
actual physical cabinet existed if one
did exist i
doubt there's photos of it also there's
only one known screen capture of the
game's title screen
the screen cap shows the name of the
game the year copyright
and says it was developed by a company
named sinister now in german
this translates to sensory deprivation
or sense deleting but it's not a good
translation so probably not a native
german speaker
there's also no evidence of a company
ever existing in germany with the name
sinister
no company anywhere had that name so no
help there now the font used for the
title itself
is actually unusual for the time the
memory required to produce this effect
was pretty significant in the early 80s
only games from huge companies like
nintendo and williams were known to put
so many resources into a title screen
and the screen
font is very close to a font used by
williams
but a couple of letters don't quite
match so again not much to go on now
there are a few sources that say
polybius was mentioned on usenet as
early as 1994.
now for you young bucks use net news
groups were a type of global message
board used during the early days of the
internet and if something was happening
on the internet
there was a news group about it google
has archived messages going back to the
beginning of usenet
but searches for polybius come up empty
and what about the gameplay itself
the sources claim that polybius was
vector-based similar to games like
tempest or battlezone
now tempest was a huge game at the time
and known for its unique graphics
so it's reasonable that people who are
playing arcade games in that time
remember tempest i definitely do
and battlezone was used by the military
as a training tool for tank crews
the army's version was called the
bradley trainer so the government
creating arcade games
that's absolutely true now what about
the story that people would get sick
playing vector-based games like polybius
or tempest or actually die
after playing certain games turns out
this is also true
an open mind is easy to expand it might
even be a good idea to heed the advice
that one game player carries on his
shirt
maybe it's a warning in 1982 14 year old
michael lopez was playing tempest with
friends at the malibu grand prix arcade
in beaverton oregon
he began to feel a weird sensation in
the back of his head
and he started losing his vision he
became dizzy stumbled outside the arcade
and threw up all over the parking lot he
then collapsed a few blocks from his
home screaming in pain
now apparently the game's flashing
lights and visual effects triggered a
migraine or a seizure
okay but then there's the case of jeff
daly who died after playing the game
berserk
that same year the daily had an unknown
congenital heart condition
apparently the stress of trying to break
the game's high score triggered a heart
attack
same for peter bukowski of calumet city
who also died of heart failure while
playing berserk
also in calumet city two teenage boys
got into a fight over a game
and one stabbed the other to death and
then there's brian morrow who was
playing asteroids for 28 straight hours
trying to break the record
he got sick and collapsed now mauro was
pounding coca-colas for hours so it's
understandable that he'd get sick from
that
now he survived but when these stories
stack up
you can see how they can lead to
paranoia about the effects of playing
video games
now it seems weird now but in the early
80s video games were a new
phenomenon and like always parents are
suspicious of anything new
fun and seemingly addictive like playing
video games
can you really blame them now game
developers job
is to make a game so fun and immersive
and addictive
that you want to throw money at it i
mean that's just as true now as it was
back then
whether it's putting coins in a slot or
micro transactions in a mobile game the
psychology is the same
game companies want you to give them
money and they want to give you hits a
dopamine
cool a role of a game company or any
corporation is to make money so nobody
disputes that they're transparent about
it
but people tend to be more suspicious of
the government than they are of
corporations
because the government not so
transparent no
now do government agencies really
conduct top secret operations using
video games at arcades
that's a rhetorical question right it is
because the answer is
yes they did
fbi's records indicate that the agency
actually
was monitoring and raiding arcades in
portland at the same time that players
were collapsing
arcades had reputations of being places
for drug activity
gambling and petty crime like
pickpocketing now though the stories
were sensationalized in the media
of course people really were gambling
over pinball games
kids really were buying and smoking weed
in arcades so how does this factor into
the polybius legend well during one
sting operation
the fbi placed microphones and cameras
inside video games to gather evidence on
criminal activity
one of the games they used was tempest
tempest again
yep now the fbi didn't care that tempest
was a vector game
all they cared about was that the
cabinet had large bevels and a lot of
room behind the glass
perfect for cameras and this fbi
operation was so extensive
that in the early 80s there was actually
a shortage of tempest cabinets in the
pacific northwest
because the feds were all over it and
apparently the feds weren't very
discreet about picking up their camera
footage
agents dressed in suits and ties would
show up in an arcade
open the machine and pull out videotape
and then leave they didn't
even bother with the coins okay but what
about the cia conducting mind control
experiments
can that possibly be true that's another
rhetorical question
of course it's true it's true
the cia became convinced the communists
had found the key
to brainwashing now the americans had to
unlock the mystery of mind control
early in the cold war the cia was
convinced that communists had discovered
a drug that would allow them to control
human minds
in response the cia began its own secret
program called
mkultra the goal was to find a mind
control drug that could be weaponized
against enemies
mk ultra which operated in the 1950s and
60s
was created and run by a chemist named
sydney gottlieb now some experiments
were covertly funded at universities and
research centers
while others were conducted in american
prisons and in detention centers in
japan
germany and the philippines and subjects
endured psychological torture ranging
from electric shock
to very high doses of lsd the gottlieb
realized that mind control was a
two-part process
first you had to destroy the existing
mind then you had to find a way to
insert a new mind into the void
now the cia didn't get too far creating
mines but they did a hell of a job
destroying them
the top secret nature of mkultra makes
it impossible to measure the human cost
of the experiments
why is that oh because the cia destroyed
the files
yeah that doesn't sound legal it's not
that's your government people
enjoy now we don't know how many people
died during mk ultra but we know some
did
and many lives were permanently
destroyed and the us government has been
experimenting on people against their
will for as long as the government has
existed
so it's not far of a stretch to think
they would use video games for this
purpose
maybe they have they have maybe they are
they are
what the united states government did
was shameful
and i am sorry
now these stories are all true but none
of them are actually connected to a game
called polybius no such game has ever
been found and if you find a game called
polybius it's either fan made or it's a
hoax
freeware developer rogue synapse is
known for creating fictional arcade
games like the one from the last
starfighter
they created a game named polybius in
2007 and their version attempts to
recreate the gameplay described in the
urban legend
including psychedelic visuals and
subliminal messages it's pretty creepy
it's kind of fun i'll link it below you
can play it's free yeah
no no thanks i'm good coward oh speaking
of the last starfighter that's a movie
from the 80s where an intergalactic
space force uses a video game to recruit
star pilots
this probably leaked into the polybius
legend allegedly players were
disappearing
and it was said they were either
abducted by the government or
were actually recruited by the
government
i've seen him come and i've seen him go
but you're the best my boy light years
ahead of the competition
[Music]
so the name polybius was probably chosen
specifically to troll people who are
into conspiracies
what polybius was a greek philosopher
born in 200 bc in megalopolis
and he's known for puzzles and
cryptography and you might have heard of
the polybius square which is a type of
cipher named for him
polybius also famously said you should
never believe anything
unless it could be verified with hard
evidence and witnesses
so yeah i think whoever started this
story was trolling us
now the urban legend of polybius emerged
in february of 2000
when a listing for the game showed up on
coinop.org a website that covers arcade
games now the
entry for polybius listed the game as
having been copyrighted in 1981
but no copyright exists and it talks
about bizarre rumors and says the game's
history is unknown
the person believed to have created the
post and this entire legend
is kurt coller the owner of coin op
after coin op created their listing for
polybius
collar tipped off game pro magazine
about it a game pro referenced polybius
in an article about secrets and lies in
video games
and as to whether polybius was a secret
or a lie gamepro said the story was
inconclusive that was a big deal in the
early 2000s
game pro was one of the largest gaming
magazines in the country so this
generated interest
a few months later the story landed on
slashdot
and if you remember the internet in the
early 2000s a mention on slashdot was a
huge deal
a legend was born now since then
polybius has been all over the media
the subject of countless investigations
it's even been referenced in pop culture
hmm never saw this one before when an
unsolved mystery gets as much attention
as this
there's going to be people claiming that
they were involved one notorious hoaxer
is someone named steven roach who posted
on coin op
that he worked on the game did he no his
story has been investigated and debunked
but it got him plenty of attention and
if kurt caller invented the story to
drum up traffic for his website
look like a child worked like a charm
so is the story of polybius true well
the psychology behind addictive games
and social media platforms like facebook
are certainly a form of mind control the
us government has a long history of
experimenting on its citizens so there's
no doubt in my mind that the government
is doing that right now
now people can become addicted to video
games and have gotten sick and even died
playing them
government agents were using arcade
games in secret operations
all of these things happened and they
all happened in portland about the same
time
so no i don't think the game ever
existed but the rest of the story
is completely true and that's why as far
as urban legends go
the story of polybius is just about
perfect
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files if you had fun or
learned anything today comment like
subscribe
share it really helps out the channel
and what do you think about polybius was
it real you have any more information
about it
let us know in the comments and until
next time be safe be kind
and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
you